foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone I'm Carol
short for Caroline I'm a data scientist
at a marketing agency I work on a
Creative Tech Team basically that means
I fall down weird rabbit holes and make
cool data toys
that is not what I'm here to talk to you
about today though
um here I am going to talk about why we
should talk about people who think they
are not data people back in 2020
uh we all kind of became armchair
experts you know sitting there pondering
in our living rooms because we couldn't
go anywhere else
if you were thinking of covid you and I
are thinking of the exact same thing all
of a sudden there was all this new
jargon that came out all these charts
all these numbers all these stats case
counts uh flatten the curve was super
popular and if you didn't know what
flattened the curve meant you just
pretended like you did so that you could
keep up with everyone else
but everyone was all of a sudden like
our lives were upfront and personal with
data it would say whether or not we
should go out whether or not we should
see people depending on the case counts
would determine should we wear a mask
should we see our friends should we stay
inside and do absolutely nothing else
but bake sourdough bread really data
became very very up close and personal
um and data have always been there in
the background but it hasn't always been
obvious and so in this I kind of had
this realization that not everyone is
interpreting data in the same way that I
interpret data
um and there was a lot of misconceptions
that this brought up for me
so that's kind of what has inspired this
I want to get us started with this quote
because maybe you're sitting out there
thinking I mean I know something about
data but like do I really have anything
to share yes you do
as we become more and more experts in
our field we kind of forget that not
everyone is directly behind us following
us down that rabbit hole and so it's
worthwhile to look around remember our
blind spots and to be able to share with
those around us
so those misconceptions I was talking
about with covid a lot of people tend to
think data are just charts or just a
bunch of numbers or charts with stuff
and more stuff
and it's just kind of this thing that
maybe you just think about a lot or
maybe it's really scary and data is
taking over or maybe data is just for
the Nerds like that's it it's hard we
don't need to think about it
and my response to these things is yes
and yes data are all of those things on
the previous slide and so much more in
improv comedy there's this theory of yes
and that you take what your partner has
given you you take the setting the
characters maybe the setup and you add
to it you say yes and you add something
new so I'm going to say yes to all of
the data things on the previous slide
and then also add something new here
so we're meeting people with where
they're at and where they're coming from
so yes to all the things and data's
creative it's not always black and white
there's a lot of gray doesn't always
have the right answers which maybe is a
terrifying thing for you to think about
but it's also super scientific it helps
us interpret the world around us and
understand information so that we can
better understand the world that we live
in and ourselves
and then as you look around data are
everywhere which makes it really fun at
least in my opinion to talk about data
because they're all over the place you
can ask my friends and family they think
they've had way too many of these
conversations I Say Never Enough
um but it's everywhere so with that in
mind
you're all formally invited to a data
party yes I realize we are already at a
data party we're at our studio conf so
here's yet another data party invite but
this one is just about talking about
data Wherever Whenever because it's cool
and obviously with a lot of excitement
if you see I'm very excited it's not
hard to get me excited about this stuff
so let's hop into this invitation of
what's really going on behind this data
party
you might have noticed so who are we
talking about you might have noticed I
throw quotes around non-datas a lot like
I'm a data person or I'm a non-data
person this is intentional
uh usually I think this is a
self-designated term to be a data person
or a non-data person but really everyone
is a data person we just exist somewhere
on this spectrum so maybe you think
you're closer to novice maybe you think
you're closer to expert honestly any of
those is good and valid it just matters
that we all recognize we all exist some
are on the Spectrum and we can meet
people with where they're at
I also want to point out that uh the
line from novice to expert is probably
not straight so don't think it's that
easy there's usually a lot of rabbit
holes a lot of twists and turns along
the way and there's also a lot of
different end paths for expert it
doesn't mean that we will necessarily
all end at the same place which is why
it's good to remember we all have blind
spots to look around think of what see
what you know and realize that people
might be on different paths and it's
worthwhile sharing things
so when you're looking around for people
to talk to about data Maybe it could be
anyone if you're working in an org maybe
it's someone who doesn't work on your
team or it's a team that you work with
more obliquely
so now that we know kind of who we
should be looking for who we should be
talking to
what should we talk to them about data
but that's a very broad category so I'm
gonna give you some more specific things
to think about
so since we're meeting people where
they're at we're saying yes and we're
taking their data knowledge and then
adding something to it what can we add
to it I like to think about this in
terms of a grid axis that's how I
organize my brain anyways so we can move
from less technical to more technical
personal to General let's think about
this in terms of music to give some
practical examples because the what
could be educational it could be
interesting
it could be a variety of things but this
is how we're going to break it down
so if we keep it really not too
Technical and very personal we can think
of Spotify wrapped in that lower left
quarter Spotify rap you've probably
heard of it it's the end of year thing
where it's like you listen to this many
Spotify artists you listen to this many
playlists this was your top five songs
it's pretty cool it's pretty fun but the
end of the day it's just counting it's
like how many times did you listen to
this song so pretty simple data
underlying it although it is for your
personal music so it's fun to see how
yours is different from your friends
if we're looking for something still not
too technical but more General music
borders is a really interesting article
put out by the pudding which if you
hadn't haven't heard of the pudding I
highly recommend you check them out it's
a very interesting data journalism
um Outlet that's very fun and
interesting rabbit holes this music
borders looks at what is the most
popular song in your city or your state
or your country and then you can compare
all around the world so what you think
is super popular and that hit song
people may have never heard about on the
other side of the world and they could
be listening to something entirely
different which is super fun to think
about as how music can connect us and be
different but also a unifying thing
and then if we're looking more technical
if we really want to go into the weeds
with someone on some data Maybe we look
at naughty Bremer's data art that pulls
in a lot of different pieces of data
into a into a visualization that really
pulls together some interesting things
and we can talk about what goes into a
good data visualization what data pieces
make something really interesting or
really unique and look at that
and then if we want to go super
technical pudding also has this really
fun thing that will rant and Rave about
your Spotify or your Apple music
streaming it is hilarious but under the
hood is an AI so you could go deep in
the weeds with someone explaining an AI
what goes into that what kind of data
are collected and really go deeper with
someone on that
so now that we know kind of some
examples of what we might be thinking
about as we're presenting
where and when should we be talking to
these people so if we're talking
something more technical it's probably
worthwhile to maybe set up an invite
with someone put it on their calendar so
they know it's coming and so they can
mentally prepare get excited maybe you
send some documentation in advance
really set up for success for this
conversation other times maybe it's a
more casual thing and you're hanging out
at a cocktail party and you're able to
just small talk away whatever latest
data Vis floated by in your Twitter that
was really interesting that day so
thinking about where and when should we
have these data conversations with folks
really depends on the what what are we
talking about who are we talking to and
at what level do we need to meet them
why are we having this party let's
remember why we're even going to go
through this so as we had these
misconceptions at the beginning or
different conceptions of data data are
science plus art it's the things the two
together
data are also an accessibility tool
we'll give you an example
let's say I want to learn about penguins
I could go to the Antarctic and stare at
Penguins all day I would probably learn
a lot about penguins and see some
interesting things I would also be very
cold and probably bored if I'm being
honest slash I have other things I want
to do in my life
so I will leave the counting of penguins
up to the people who get super pumped
about penguins
but in that I can take their data and
look at it in different ways so maybe I
will look at their data and read it in a
book or in some text like this and see
ah cool longest flipper length of this
penguin is this maybe I would summarize
the data in a table and just have the
summary stats like that maybe have a
little bit less context but I still
still see the data in some way
or maybe I see data as a chart and all
three of these show the same kinds of
data but in three different ways which
is super important because data
themselves summarize information so that
we can understand the world around us
and we can present in different ways
dataviz and accessibility in charts is a
whole other conversation I could
probably make this chart better I could
probably make it much worse to be
accessible but it's interesting to think
about
how we can show data and what we can
learn from each of these because you've
learned different things or you might
realize different things by looking at
the exact same data in a different way
this is also super important because
we're not always talking about penguins
although we might want to this also
matters because when we're in our daily
lives and we have news feeds come up
with different stats or different charts
we want to be able to understand those
and we want others to be able to
understand them and realize what do I
need to be understanding about this
chart what is the key piece of
information I need out of this graph and
then also to realize is this chart
leading me astray could this be fake
news and being able to realize when a
chart might be misleading is a very
important skill to have and so by
introducing people to some simpler
Concepts or to even have these
conversations allows people to realize
and be able to understand data better in
their daily lives as they go about them
so maybe you are totally ready to get
out there to go for it to start talking
about data and you are pumped
if that is the case go forth do it I
fully support you but maybe you want
some more resources maybe you need to
sign up for a newsletter there's some
that will send out a chart weekly break
it down for you and make it really
interesting you can listen to a podcast
read a book this is one of my favorite
books uh you look like a thing and I
Love You by Janelle Shane it isn't I'm
getting some head nods it's a hilarious
book
um it's a all about AI the title is a
pickup line written by AI so I feel like
that should say enough or why you should
go read this or just use that on your
next thing you look like a thing and I
love you
try it out and let me know how that goes
I would love to hear it
but really this is just to prepare you
to give you some thoughts of what to
talk about when you're talking with
people about data
and my best advice is really just go out
there and do it it might feel super
awkward and super weird at the beginning
and people might give you some weird
looks embrace it data is super exciting
and we just need to jump in
so for this last thing I want to close
on a story
so back in 2020 the first week of
working from home I was super inspired
by Georgia Lupe's data portraits I
thought this is super awesome I want to
do the exact same thing for my team what
a fun thing to have on our desks when we
go back to the office like a little name
tag plate a little fun welcome back
thing spoiler we never went back to the
office
so I still made them though and it was
super fun uh I made them we talked about
them it was super fun to have people
guess who was who because I just showed
them this screen and I was like guess
which one you are
some people got it some people didn't it
was fun it was fun all right
um but it was an interesting way that we
could talk about within our data team to
learn how can we best support each other
while we're all working remote how do we
best work remote and having those
conversations in a way that maybe you
don't typically have it wasn't like
forced by HR but it was this fun
creative data-driven way
additionally our creative lead caught
wind of this project and he's like hey
Carol I heard you did some cool data
thing and I was like yes
and he's like I'm gonna have you present
that to the entire creative team and I
was like really okay at the time I was
working on a team that did primarily
like your classic marketing analytics
meaning how many people clicked on this
email how many people should we Target
on Twitter how should we set up our
tagging specification so kind of like
the bookends of a project like we'd help
set it up and then we report on it after
by presenting this project to our
creative team that we're mostly what
they would self-designate themselves as
non-data people it blew their minds that
data could be this creative this
interesting this Innovative and it was
really interesting for me also because
then I got to have all these
conversations after the fact with people
about how can we incorporate data in new
and innovative ways that we hadn't
considered incorporating into our
projects previously
and it was really interesting because we
were able when you're able to let data
out of the box to let your creative side
and your data side work together we can
do so many cool things with data we can
do interesting projects and change the
way that we perceive
the world around us so
getting back to the point of why is it
beneficial for us data people to talk to
these non-data people
one it's good to like help them
understand the world around them so they
can interpret charts that's all fine and
good it is also good for us because then
selfishly we get to work on cooler stuff
if people are also pumped about data and
we ourselves are enthusiastic about it
then we are able to bring these passions
together to share them and to do really
cool things
so thank you thank you for coming to my
data party I encourage you to go start
your own
[Music]